yeah welcome to a new game against very
strong I am here dankest I played him
recently McCaw pokrovsky okay um Quincy
to III let's play III disposed to the
same ish okay yeah prob Nia doesn't
matter let's play fun and let's not
catch on so quickly g4s often or an
interesting way to to play okay let's
all right let's have a quick look at
this should I or Bishop g5 maybe am
Bishop g5 provoking this weakness
hmm yeah
hmm g4 is going to f4
okay that's Queen d2
and
interesting just preparing native form
I cannot go g3t because he he just takes
that here John probably I need to
it's not so clear that this kind of
setup is so great I mean he can go
neither for but what exactly is the
positive thing about that
rg3 immediately not sure
hmm yeah not sure
I cannot tolerate the night there follow
so G 30 Bishop c203 three
yeah I need to prevent a five
yeah it's a it's a very difficult
position oh this was too quick I'm
allowing this is not exactly great it's
not maybe not terrible but it wasn't it
wasn't necessary at all to do okay let's
get going down
yeah so night f5 now probably or is h5
night h5 and it's probably blocking the
H file for me so not so great so kingi
to rook edge one
kingi to walking some something else mmm
i probably this is this is the only way
to go about that okay he wants to play
Queen a6 attack attack them que Bonita
yeah yeah but ok this this I must play
anyway so I'm i need to go for for a
tech now against the king and i think
it's it's possible to do so just a
question how
I don't want to defend this passively
this would be wouldn't be great kingi
One Nights efficacy for Quincy form
tweenage to check and queen age five he
doesn't have a check then and i have i
have check on g6 now you can take III
this is this is the problem and one
problem at least and okay but i always
have this this counter attack okay so
the key and porn endgame is this a draw
judge must be a drone
Rock you can of course play on time and
as usual I expect expect him to do that
is really nothing before I can take King
takes d5 and even winning
and he's got nothing on the queenside he
also cannot go over to a six because of
g5 there's no way at all to to win
I don't I don't hmm
no I was briefly thinking if I could try
to win but it's probably a no it's no
way King to age three and okay maybe he
needs to move back to age six King age
four and so on but it's not not forced
or something no yeah there is nothing
the problem is he can never play this
breakthrough which is the only possible
idea because of e5 and and one of those
pawns will hear this is this is covered
he cannot go here so the pawn is is
promoting and this is the only idea
basically that black has he cannot go as
mentioned all the way back here so let's
just put it on the board and now I'm
breaking through so black cannot make
any any progress yeah it was a very
curry closed position and turn
93 was probably a bit to be too hasty
maybe maybe I don't know yeah a
complicated game and I think I draw at
the end of service a fair result thanks
for watching